"HANNITY" IS NEXT.
HI, SEAN.
>> Sean: TUCKER, THANK YOU.
GREAT SHOW.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
3, 2, 1, 9:00 IN THE EAST, 352
DELEGATES ARE UP FOR GRABS.
FOX NEWS IS PROJECTING JOE BIDEN
WILL WIN MISSOURI AND
MISSISSIPPI.
POLLS HAVE CLOSED IN MICHIGAN.
FOX NEWS CAN MAKE A CALL IN THAT
RACE.
MY OPENING MONOLOGUE IN JUST A
MINUTE.
FIRST, WE HEAD TO OUR DECISION
DESK.
BRET AND MARTHA STANDING BY WITH
THE BIG NEWS.
>> SEAN, IT’S 9:00 IN NEW YORK.
THE DECISION DESK CAN PREDICT
THAT JOE BIDEN WILL BEAT BERNIE
SANDERS IN THE CRUCIAL STATE OF
MICHIGAN.
WHICH SANDERS WON OF COURSE FOUR
YEARS AGO.
>> IT’S THE BIGGEST VICTORY OF
THE NIGHT FOR BIDEN WHO EARLIER,
AS YOU SAID, WON MISSISSIPPI AND
ALSO MISSOURI.
THE FOX PROJECTION IS BASED ON
OUR POLLING OF EARLY VOTERS AND
THOSE THAT CAST THEIR BALLOTS
TODAY AS WELL AS DATA FROM
SAMPLE PRECINCTS.
WE’LL BE BACK WITH UPDATES
THROUGHOUT THE EVENING AND A
11:00 P.M. ROUNDUP OF ALL OF THE
ELECTION NEWS TONIGHT, SEAN.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Sean: BRET AND MARTHA.
THANK YOU.
BILL HEMMER NOW FOR WHO IS GOING
TO BE IMPACTED DELEGATE-WISE IN
TERMS OF THE DELEGATE COUNT.
YOU GET TO 15%, IT’S
PROPORTIONATE DISTRIBUTION.
BILL, WHAT DO YOU GOT?
BILL HEMMER IS SOMEWHERE.
>> SEAN, I CAN HEAR YOU.
YOU WANT TO HANG WITH ME A
MOMENT HERE?
>> Sean: OF COURSE, I DO.
>> I’M GOING TO TELL YOU A
STORY.
OKAY?
TELL YOU A STORY THAT I’M SEEING
HERE THAT IS VERY SIGNIFICANT
FOR PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND.
TAKE YOU TO MICHIGAN.
I WANT YOU TO FOCUS ON TWO
THINGS, SEAN.
41% OF THE VOTE.
BIDEN OVER BERNIE SANDERS.
THIS IS WHERE SANDERS IS
UNDERPERFORMING AND BIDEN IS
OVERPERFORMING.
SIGNIFICANT.
THIS IS UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
BERNIE SANDERS WAS THERE
SATURDAY NIGHT.
15,000 PEOPLE.
AOC WAS THERE AS WELL.
BERNIE IS 49% OVER JOE BIDEN.
FOUR YEARS AGO, THIS IS WHERE
SANDERS WAS IN THE SAME COUNTY.
AT 55%.
HE’S 5% OVERPERFORMING FOUR
YEARS LATER.
THIS IS DETROIT, WAYNE COUNTY.
OAKLAND COUNTY SUBURBS, CRITICAL
IN THE FALL.
THE SUBURBS OUT OF DETROIT.
JOE BIDEN IS ALMOST AT 50% OF
THE VOTE THERE IN OAKLAND
COUNTY.
FOUR YEARS AGO, HILLARY CLINTON
WAS DOING 51%.
AGAIN, BIDEN IS OVERPERFORMING
IN CRITICAL AREAS.
HANG WITH ME.
HERE IS YOUR CALENDAR IN MARCH.
IN TWO WEEKS, YOU HAVE THE
GEORGIA PRIMARY.
105 DELEGATES IN TWO WEEKS.
NEXT WEEK, WE HAVE BIG ONES,
TOO.
ARIZONA, FLORIDA, ILLINOIS AND
OHIO.
FLORIDA IS THE BIGGEST ONE OF
ALL NEXT TUESDAY AT 219
DELEGATES.
HERE’S WHAT WE FIND IN TERMS OF
POLLING IN FLORIDA.
AS OF TODAY, SEAN, IN THE STATE
OF FLORIDA, JOE BIDEN IS
CLOCKING 61%.
EVEN IF IT’S NOT ACCURATE, IF
IT’S CLOSE TO BEING ACCURATE,
YOU CAN MAKE A FAIR ARGUMENT FOR
THE FOLLOWING WAY THE RACE IS
SHAPING UP.
ALL OF THIS AREA IN THE
SOUTHEAST, WE CALLED MISSISSIPPI
FOR JOE BIDEN.
LOOK WHAT HE DID IN ALABAMA.
63% OF THE VOTE THERE.
TEN DAYS AGO, SEAN, IT WAS ONLY
TEN DAYS AGO, SOUTH CAROLINA.
TEN DAYS AGO HE WAS ALMOST 50%
OF THE VOTE IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
MY POINT IS YOU CAN NOW START TO
MAKE AN ARGUMENT FOR GEORGIA IN
TWO WEEKS, MAYBE FLORIDA NEXT
WEEK AND THE WHOLE PART OF THIS
COUNTRY GOES JOE BIDEN’S WAY.
IT’S STARTING TO SHAPE UP A RACE
IN FAVOR OF THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY.
HE’S OUTPERFORMING BERNIE
SANDERS IN PLACES WHERE HE
SHOULD NOT IF SANDERS WANTS TO
CATCH UP.
>> Sean: GREAT ANALYSIS.
WE’LL BE CHECKING IN THROUGHOUT
THE EVENING ON THE BIG BOARD.
THAT TELLS THE STORY.
WE’LL HAVE THE LIVE UPDATES
THROUGHOUT THE HOUR AS THE
CRITICAL PRIMARY NIGHT UNFOLDS.
AS IT STANDS NOW, QUID PRO QUO
JOE HAS CEMENTED HIS FRONTRUNNER
STATUS OVER BERNIE SANDERS.
JOE BIDEN IS STRUGGLING.
EVERYBODY SEES IT.
THE MEDIA MOB AND DEMOCRATIC
PARTY MAY TRY TO IGNORE IT.
IT IS NOW OFFICIAL AND IT IS
BEYOND ALARMING IF WE’RE GOING
TO BE HONEST AND TRUTHFUL AS A
COUNTRY.
FRANKLY, IT’S HARD TO WATCH.
THE CONFUSION, THE INABILITY TO
FINISH THOUGHTS, THE
NEVER-ENDING DAILY GAFFES, THE
BURSTS OF ANGER SHOULD CONCERN
EVERY AMERICAN.
LOOKS LIKE HE WILL BE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
THIS SHOULD BE REGARDLESS OF ANY
POLITICAL VIEW.
HE’S NOW FORGOTTEN BARACK
OBAMA’S NAME.
HE CONFUSED HIS WIFE FOR HIS
SISTER.
HE CALLED SUPER TUESDAY SUPER
THURSDAY.
HE MIXED UP CHRIS WALLACE FOR
CHUCK TODD, WHICH WAS AN INSULT
TO CHRIS WALLACE.
HE SAID 150 MILLION AMERICANS
DIED FROM GUN VIOLENCE.
NOT TRUE.
HE TOLD A CROWD IN
SOUTH CAROLINA HE WAS RUNNING
FOR THE SENATE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, WE HAVE
EXAMPLES JUST FROM THE PAST FEW
WEEKS.
WE HAVE OUR LIST.
IT’S ONGOING.
HE CANNOT CONTROL HIS AGITATION.
TOTALLY ENRAGED JOE BIDEN WHEN A
CONSTRUCTION WORKER AT AN AUTO
PLANT DARED TO ASK HIM ABOUT
THIS CLIP.
WE’LL SHOW YOU THE CLIP FIRST
BECAUSE IT TURNS OUT, THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKER AT THE AUTO
PLANT WAS RIGHT ABOUT BIDEN
TALKING ABOUT TAKING ASSAULT
RIFLES.
HERE’S THE CLIP THAT PROVES THE
GUY IS RIGHT WHICH WE’LL PLAY IN
A SECOND.
>> SO TO GUN OWNERS OUT THERE
THAT SAY A BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
MEANS THEY’RE COMING FOR MY
GUNS.
>> BINGO, YOU’RE RIGHT IF YOU
HAVE AN ASSAULT WEAPON.
THEY SHOULD BE ILLEGAL, PERIOD.
>> Sean: HE SAID IT.
SO MAYBE BIDEN AGAIN JUST
DOESN’T REMEMBER SAYING THAT.
HE ONLY SAID IT IN AUGUST OF
2019.
MAYBE HE DOESN’T REMEMBER THAT
HE RECENTLY ANOINTED BETO
O’ROURKE TO LEAD HIS GUN
CONFISCATION POLICY.
BETO SAY WE’RE GOING TO TAKE
YOUR AR-15s OR IN BIDEN’S CASE
14s.WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE,
WHAT I’M ABOUT TO SHOW YOU
SHOULD BE CONCERNING TO EVERY
AMERICAN.
THIS IS ONE INCIDENT OF MANY
INCIDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKING
PLACE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Sean: THE ONLY PROBLEM IS,
THE CONSTRUCTION WORKER AT AN
AUTO PLANT WAS 1000% RIGHT.
JOE SAYS HE’S FULL OF BEEP AND
HE WANTS HIS VOTE.
THEN HE SHHH’S A STAFFER.
THAT’S NOT ALL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN COMPARING THE
SECOND AMENDMENT TO YELLING FIRE
IN A CROWDED ROOM.
HE SAYS MY SONS LOVE HUNTING AND
THAT HE’S NOT TRYING TO TAKE
AWAY GUNS WHILE HE WAS ON TAPE
SAYING THE SAME THING WHICH HE
IMMEDIATELY CONTRADICTS.
WATCH THIS.
>> Sean: YOUR A HORSE’S ASS.
IN ALL MY LIFE, I THOUGHT I
OWNED 15s.
I DIDN’T KNOW THEY WERE 14s.
THAT IS THE FRONTRUNNER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, SHH-ING A
WOMAN ON HIS STAFF.
BY THE WAY, WHO SEEMS TO BE
TRYING TO HELP HIM GET OUT OF
ANOTHER TROUBLING SITUATION.
GREAT WAY TO TREAT PEOPLE,
TRYING TO SAVE YOU FROM
YOURSELF, JOE.
THEN STICKING HIS FINGER IN THE
FACE OF A CONSTRUCTION WORKER AT
AN AUTO PLANT CALLING HIM A
HORSE’S ASS SAYING THAT HE’S
FULL OF BLEEP.
ACCORDING TO ONE CBC REPORTER,
BIDEN THREATENED TO SLAP THE
MAN.
ON TOP OF IT ALL, HE CAN’T
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN AN AR-15 AND
14.
STAFF TRIED TO RUSH HIM OUT OF
THE ROOM.
GET OUT OF THE WAY.
MAYBE NOT A BIG DEAL NORMALLY.
BUT WITH JOE, IT’S CUMULATIVELY
A HUGE DEAL.
THIS TYPE OF AGITATED BEHAVIOR
IS PART OF AN INCREASING
DISTURBING PATTERN.
THE PAST FEW MONTHS, HE’S CALLED
ONE VOTER FAT, A DAMN LIAR.
CALLED A YOUNG WOMAN A DOG FACED
PONY SOLDIER.
THAT’S THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
WE HAVE TAPE OF ALL OF IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WAS A DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
EVER BEEN TO A CAUCUS?
NO, YOU HAVEN’T.
YOU’RE A LYING DOG FACED PONY
SOLDIER.
NOW YOU HAVE TO BE HONEST.
I’M GOING TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
>> YOUR A DAMN LIAR.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
NOBODY HAS EVER SAID THAT.
YOU WANT TO CHECK MY SHAPE?
LET’S DO PUSHUPS.
LET’S DO WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
DO.
>> YOU SAID I SET UP MY SON TO
WORK IN AN OIL COMPANY.
>> I HAVE TWO WORDS FOR YOU --
>> HERE’S THE DEAL.
>> WE HAVE TO STOP BUILDING AND
REPLACING PIPELINES.
>> GO VOTE FOR SOMEONE ELSE.
NEW CAMPAIGN SLOGAN.
DOES THAT SEEM LIKE THE BEHAVIOR
OF A GROUNDED BALANCED LUCID
INDIVIDUAL?
JOE 303030 OR ON OTHER
OCCASIONS, JOE 233 -- BETTER GET
IT RIGHT.
303300 IS RUNNING FOR THE
HARDEST, THE MOST DEMANDING, THE
MOST POWERFUL JOB IN THE WORLD.
THERE’S NO HARDER JOB THAN BEING
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
SO I’LL ASK AGAIN, DOES THIS
77-YEAR-OLD GUY WE’RE WATCHING
EVERY DAY NOW, DOES HE HAVE THE
STAMINA, DOES HE HAVE THE FOCUS,
THE ALERTNESS, THE MENTAL FOCUS,
MENTAL TOUGHNESS AND THE MENTAL
STABILITY TO BE PRESIDENT?
IT’S A FAIR QUESTION.
IS THIS HOW HE’S GOING TO TREAT
WORLD LEADERS?
QUID PRO JOE LOOKS FRAIL TO ME.
IS HE GOING TO INVITE PUTIN TO A
FIGHT OR PUSHUP CONTEXT OR
LITTLE ROCKET MAN?
THEY’LL KICK HIS ASS.
IT’S SO BAD THAT THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN ARE TRYING TO COVER FOR
QUID PRO QUO JOE.
TRYING TO KEEP HIM OUT OF THE
PUBLIC SPOTLIGHT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY’RE HIDING
HIM FROM THE WORLD.
A GREAT CAMPAIGN STRATEGY.
HIDE YOUR CANDIDATE.
WE CAN’T TRUST WHAT HE’S GOING
TO DO OR SAY.
A DISASTER.
ACCORDING TO "THE WASHINGTON
POST" IN HIS RALLY IN ST. LOUIS
THIS WEEKEND, HE SPOKE FOR A
WHOPPING 7 MINUTES.
I CAN SEE PEOPLE WAITING IN LINE
FOR HOURS TO HEAR THAT IN
KANSAS CITY.
HE SPOKE FOR 12 MINUTES.
HIS LONGEST SPEECH OF THE
WEEKEND DIDN’T HIT THE 15-MINUTE
MARK.
HIS BIG RALLY TONIGHT WAS
CANCELLED AFTER THE CAMPAIGN
CITED CORONAVIRUS CONCERNS
ALTHOUGH HE WILL SPEAK IN
PHILADELPHIA.
LIKE FATHER LIKE SON, HUNTER
BIDEN IS USING THE CORONAVIRUS
AS AN EXCUSE.
REMEMBER, HE DENIED PATERNITY IN
A CASE IN ARKANSAS.
NOW HE’S SKIPPING OUT OF CHILD
SUPPORT HEARINGS BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
I’D ARGUE BECAUSE HE DOESN’T
WANT TO TURN OVER HIS FINANCES.
THAT WOULD EXPOSE HIM IN THE
BURISMA CASE AND CHINA CASE.
BY THE WAY, ARKANSAS HAS ZERO
CASES OF CORONAVIRUS.
BACK TO QUID PRO QUO JOE.
HE CAN’T BE TRUSTED TO SPEAK
MORE THAN SEVEN MINUTES BY HIS
OWN CAMPAIGN.
THAT IS SEVEN MINUTES WITH A
TELEPROMPTER.
HE WANTS TO LEAD THE FREE WORLD.
LET’S PAUSE.
LET’S TAKE THAT IN.
LET’S THINK ABOUT THAT.
OF COURSE, WHEN QUID PRO QUO JOE
ACTUALLY DOES HOLD AN EVENT MORE
THAN SEVEN MINUTES, IT’S A
STRUGGLE.
EVERY TIME A STRUGGLE IS
GUARANTEED TO ENSUE.
MONDAY’S RALLY IN DETROIT BECAME
TOTALLY DERAILED AFTER AN
INTERRUPTION FROM A FEW
ANTI-NAFTA PROTESTERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DIDN’T -- ARE YOU A DONALD
TRUMP -- THAT’S ALL RIGHT.
LET HIM GO.
IT’S NOT A TRUMP RALLY.
THE BERNIE BROS ARE HERE.
LET HIM GO.
FOLKS, FOLKS, LET HIM GO.
THAT’S OKAY.
>> Sean: HEREIN LIES ANOTHER
SERIOUS PROBLEM FOR QUID PRO QUO
JOE.
HE CAN’T HIDE FROM WHAT IS A
REAL HORRIFIC TRACK RECORD.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
HERE’S A FEW OF JOE’S TOP
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
LET’S SEE.
NAFTA, DISASTROUS TRADE DEAL.
OH, GIVEING MULLAHS $150 BILLION
IN CASH.
AND MILLIONS LOST THEIR DOCTORS
AND MILLIONS LOST THEIR PLANS.
37% OF THE COUNTRY HAS ONE OBAMA
EXCHANGE CARE OPTION.
THAT’S IT.
AND PREMIUMS, AVERAGE FAMILY,
DID YOU SAVE $2,500 ON AVERAGE?
NO.
WE’RE PAYING 200% MORE.
LET’S NOT FORGET THE HORRIFIC
ECONOMIC TRACK RECORD.
I TELL IT OFTEN.
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS FOOD
STAMPS, LOWER LABOR
PARTICIPATION RATE SINCE THE
70s.
THE LOWEST HOMEOWNERSHIP, THE
WORST RECOVERY SINCE THE 40s,
MORE DEBT THAN THE FOUR PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS COMBINED.
NOT A BAD RECORD UNDER TRUMP.
NEW TRADE DEALS, THE WALL BEING
BUILT, PROMISES MADE AND KEPT
OPEN THE TRADE DEALS AND GUESS
WHAT?
AMERICA IS DOING BETTER THAN
EVER.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC IN THIS
COUNTRY.
NOW, BY THE WAY, AN ATTACK
AGAINST THE ADMINISTRATION OVER
A VIRUS.
APPARENTLY THAT IS FAIR GAME.
17,000 AMERICANS DIED FROM H1N1.
THAT WAS THE SWINE FLU.
THAT WAS HANDLED UNDER BIDEN
OBAMA.
BIDEN VOTED IN FAVOR OF THE IRAQ
WAR, BUT HE DID AN INTERVIEW AND
HE TOLD LAWRENCE O’DONNELL AT
MSDNC THAT HE DID VOTE FOR A WAR
TO PREVENT A WAR FROM HAPPENING.
HE VOTED FOR A WAR TO PREVENT A
WAR FROM HAPPENING.
EXCUSE ME?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE REASON I VOTED THE WAY I
DID WAS TO TRY TO PREVENT A WAR
FROM HAPPENING.
REMEMBER, THE THREAT WAS THE GO
TO WAR.
THE ARGUMENT WAS BECAUSE SADDAM
HUSSEIN HAD WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
SO HE SAID THAT I NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE SECURITY COUNCIL
TO AGREE TO SEND IN INSPECTORS
TO PUT PRESSURE ON SADDAM TO
FIND OUT WHETHER OR NOT HE’S
USING -- PRODUCING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
AT THE TIME I SAID THAT’S YOUR
REASON?
ALL RIGHT.
I GET IT.
THAT WAS THE -- THE RATIONALE
WAS THAT’S THE WAY NOT TO GO TO
WAR.
>> Sean: I VOTED FOR A WAR SO WE
WOULDN’T HAVE A WAR.
OKAY.
DOESN’T MATTER HOW SHORT BIDEN’S
SPEECHES GET.
HE CAN’T HIDE FROM HIS HORRIFIC
TRACK RECORD.
HE CAN’T HIDE FROM THE FACT THAT
YOU’RE NOT GETTING A BILLION
UNLESS YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO EXPERIENCE
SON HUNTER WHO WAS PAID
MILLIONS.
CAN’T HIDE THE INVESTIGATION
ONGOING THAT IS HAPPENING IN
UKRAINE.
DONALD TRUMP HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT.
ALSO HAPPENING WITH SENATOR RON
JOHNSON IN THE U.S. SENATE.
HOW MANY OTHER MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS DID ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER MAKE THERE?
THAT WILL BE FAIR GAME IN THE
NEXT 238 DAYS.
HE SURE AS HELL CAN’T HIDE THE
INCREASING AMOUNT OF LET’S BE
CHARITABLE, SENIOR MOMENTS ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND POTENTIAL
HEAD-TO-HEAD MATCHUP WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NO STONE WILL BE LEFT UNTURNED.
YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL BE
THE ULTIMATE JURY.